oh there goes he'll know it's bill oh ah
the shot please don't hang up I know
you're mad about the diandra trade but I
can't control the GM dust you're the GM
exactly I take the troll what I do
plus you still got this hey Phil see
wait coach what are you doing here yeah
ultra JJ Watt for your sourdough starter
and three rolls are doing the paper
you'll do - okay I know you're bored
during quarantine but stop making
impulsive decisions you're gonna
scramble we could probably get rid of
your offensive line again
okay I'm back for good now yo I stuck
here huh okay a trip of a couch I know
you're upset been returned for DeAndre
we got a second-round pick can't really
evaluate the players though right now is
it probably gonna pick the guy who
interviews best on FaceTime just to meet
you at beef gums no we're cool see yo
what up nuke you know real quick how do
you push someone over in in it okay here
remove coach from Chet nice plants bro
oh no that's calamari it was good to
show if you liked this video subscribe
below for more or we're not Jason and
Jason McCord II know you're Devin I'm
pretty sure you're Devin which one of us
is Devin you me I'll be Devin thanks
Jason